is she close by okay if any of my 213
followers is in the Midtown mall we just
found a dope little girl and her parents
aren't here but she's fine she's with us
but what's your name Madonna Rihanna
Ilana good Donna Wow
dude that's good
[Music]
put on one second right so we're going
to security but we're writing the
escalator which is more fun and it gives
us more time with Madonna totally dude
no I mean it's insane like what she's -
I'm 30 I mean I couldn't literally be
her mom I mean if I was just walking
around this you know the mall by myself
and people saw me - shopping with her
they'd be like that's a mom and her kid
yeah please me I'm crazy now she not
[Music]
okay Donna you have taught us so much
yeah we're really gonna miss you okay
man we could just do it like a double
yeah yeah double cheek is ready excuse
me what the are you doing with my
child
Abby College Abby did you take Bella no
we didn't sneak her she was clearly
stranded you should keep better track of
your kids Oh grow up Abby we're 30 what
are you filming her bitch bitch
[Music]
[Applause]
but now what a bitch like what a mess
like we're so not pedophiles no I mean
her name is cheese but it's not really
cheese no whatever her name is
listen all this girl wanted to do in
college was like ecstasy and take group
showers ones that I never even wanted to
be a partner by the way even if she
weren't of asking I would have never
done it yeah she was a bunch of kids and
she did better than me now do you think
she's better than me
[Music]
a lot of what happened oh god okay so
[Applause]
[Music]
let's do this quick before she gets back
happy birthday Abbie's I hope you have
the most amazing when I love you so much
I hope the cities are everything you
expect them to be and I'm really happy
it's happening for you before me you are
older than me that's why I think God
dude I remember my 30s all I had was a
leaper a freaking beat where nobody had
forget cell phones every two minutes
checking your phone I'm so happy I
didn't grow
is every happy birthday I'm so excited
to celebrate this momentous occasion
with you I feel like this is your year
so we need to do something with it if I
know not be able to schedule
she is just about finished this cute is
this
you
[Music]
thank you guys so much for all this
I also saw the new butt video okay the
lady doth not protest though though it
could they're good pants for but really
good
[Music]